[Música]
15 votaciones y cuatro días después el
republicano Kevin mccarthy fue elegido
como presidente de la cámara de
representantes de Estados Unidos pero su
Victoria es parcial Pues hay divisiones
dentro de su partido y su posición es
débil ante las concesiones que tuvo que
hacerle al ala más radical
faltan menos de tres horas para que
acabe el cese unilateral de hostilidades
que prometió Rusia Aunque Moscú
reconoció que sí ha hecho operaciones
militares asegura que es en defensa a
los ataques de Ucrania mientras que
Washington señalan que la ofensiva rusa
nunca paró
y dos hombres fueron ejecutados en Irán
se trata de muhammad y karami Y si Jet
Mohamed joseini Quienes fueron
declarados culpables del asesinato de un
oficial paramilitar durante las
protestas así ya van cuatro
manifestantes ejecutados desde las
movilizaciones por la muerte de
buenas tardes y bienvenidos a la
actualidad internacional aquí en France
24 yo soy María Clara calle
iniciamos con la noticia de Estados
Unidos la elección del representante
republicano Kevin mccarthy como el
presidente de la cámara de
representantes la votación se extendió
casi hasta la una de la madrugada y
luego de 15 rondas finalmente logró ser
elegido con la mayoría simple sin
embargo seis republicanos del ala más
radical se opusieron hasta el final por
lo que mccarthy llega al liderazgo de la
cámara en una frágil posición política
veamos
el sueño se hace realidad para Kevin
mccarthy por fin puede dirigir la sesión
118 del Congreso de los Estados Unidos
como presidente de la cámara de
representantes mi responsabilidad última
no es para con mi partido mi conferencia
o incluso nuestro congreso mi
responsabilidad nuestra responsabilidad
es para con nuestro país
para hacerse con el mazo de presidente
el californiano tuvo que sufrir 14
humillantes derrotas en las votaciones
de la cámara y el Capitolio se convirtió
en el teatro de un bochornoso drama
político
durante la décimo cuarta Ronda de
votaciones se registraron algunas
escenas increíbles en un momento dado
mccarthy se enfrentó a Matt Gates de
Florida quien se encontraba sentado
junto a Lauren Bubble de Colorado dos de
los últimos residentes de la veintena de
miembros del freedom Cocos el grupo
republicano más derechista que había
estado bloqueando su candidatura esta
semana la batalla por la presidencia de
mccarthy se convirtió en un embarazosa
guerra interna para el partido
republicano que ganó el control de la
cámara en las elecciones de mitad de
mandato con una mayoría muy ajustada
hizo tantas concesiones a los partidos
de la línea dura para ganarse sus votos
que Gates llegó a bromear con que su
bloque se estaba quedando sin cosas que
pedir
es el último hombre gombie El Hombre de
goma no tiene principios seguros lo
único que le importa es conseguir la
presidencia probablemente será el
portavoz más débil de la historia
moderna del país y será rehén de estos
20 o 21 republicanos radicales
la elección de presidente de la cámara
representantes más largas desde el siglo
XIX es otro revés para la democracia
estadounidense tuvo lugar en el mismo
edificio que fue atacado por una turba
de partidarios de Trump hace dos años
dos trenes subterráneos se chocaron en
el norte de Ciudad de México por ahora
las autoridades confirman que una
persona murió Y al menos 35 más están
heridas en hospitales desde la capital
mexicana a nuestro corresponsal Mario
carbonel nos trae los detalles
pasadas las nueve de la mañana de este
sábado ocurrió un accidente en el
sistema de transporte colectivo metro de
la Ciudad de México en la línea 3 entre
las estaciones Potrero y la raza en
dirección a Indios Verdes hacia el norte
de la ciudad hubo un choque de trenes
que ha dejado hasta el momento de manera
oficial un saldo de una persona
fallecida mientras que 35 personas han
sido trasladadas en ambulancias a
distintos hospitales de la Ciudad de
México pues sus lesiones requieren
atención médica la jefa de gobierno de
la ciudad cla no se encontraba en la
capital del país al momento del
accidente ella estaba por iniciar un
acto político en el Estado de Michoacán
al saber de la situación se regresó vía
aérea a la ciudad para dar seguimiento a
las investigaciones peritos de la
Fiscalía de la Ciudad de México ya se
encuentran trabajando para determinar a
la causa exacta de este accidente el
presidente Andrés Manuel López Obrador
vía Twitter ha expresado sus
condolencias por la persona que hasta el
momento ha perdido la vida y se mantiene
atento al seguimiento de esta situación
sobre todo por la salud de los de los
heridos que están insisto siendo
atendidos en distintas clínicas de
hospitales de la capital del país
el presidente de Colombia Gustavo Petro
viajó por segunda vez a Caracas para
reunirse con su homólogo de Venezuela
Nicolás Maduro sin embargo se conoce
poco de lo que están dialogando los dos
mandatarios en Miraflores Lo que sí es
cierto es que es el segundo encuentro
después del que tuvieron hace dos meses
en el que discutieron el trabajo
bilateral en temas como la economía del
comercio la migración y la seguridad de
los dos países luego de Caracas Pedro
viajará el domingo a Santiago de Chile
para reunirse con el presidente Gabriel
y en noticias de la guerra en Ucrania el
Ministerio de defensa de Rusia señaló
que continúan honrando el cese al fuego
unilateral que ordenó al presidente
Vladimir Putin y al que le quedan pocas
horas sin embargo las autoridades
ucranianas y la población civil han
denunciado que los ataques se mantienen
en los últimos minutos el kremlin señala
que solo se defienden ante la
contraofensiva de la historia es de
Andrés triviño
Rusia asegura estar respetando su
promesa el Ministerio de defensa del
kremlin señaló que las tropas honrarán
el cese y el fuego unilateral decretado
por la navidad ortodoxa sin embargo
admitieron haber atacado las posiciones
ucranianas en respuesta a la
contraofensiva de kiev a pesar del
bombardeo de artillería de las fuerzas
ucranianas en áreas civiles y posiciones
rusas un grupo de nuestras tropas
seguirán manteniendo el alto el fuego
declarado hasta la medianoche quien
rechazó la oferta del alto del fuego de
Moscú y junto con el pentágono al
acusado a las tropas rusas no respetar
su alto el fuego unilateral y de
utilizarlo como una estrategia de guerra
para ganar terreno el peligro de ataques
aéreos y con misiles permanece en toda
Ucrania los principales esfuerzos del
enemigo se centran en intentar capturar
completamente la región de donievsk
dentro de la frontera administrativa
lleva a cabo operaciones ofensivas en la
dirección de mahmud Mientras tanto en
sus habitantes denunciaron que los
ataques no han cesado durante la
supuesta tregua rusa
creo que nos están engañando es bastante
obvio si alguien hace una promesa debe
cumplirla
el alto el fuego sabes cómo funciona
cuando Putin dice que hay un alto el
fuego en realidad es al revés Ellos nos
bombardearon mucho ayer durante la noche
fue más o menos tranquilo así suele ser
un día hay bombardeos el otro día es más
tranquilo
la iglesia ortodoxa celebra la Navidad
el 7 de enero Aunque la principal
iglesia ortodoxa de Ucrania ha rechazado
la autoridad de Moscú y muchos creyentes
han cambiado su calendario para celebrar
la Navidad el 25 de diciembre como en
occidente
siete de enero se cumplen ocho años del
atentado contra la redacción en París de
la publicación satírica
en el que murieron 12 personas y la
publicación mantiene su línea editorial
decidió conmemorar El Aniversario
haciendo una convocatoria de caricaturas
de la yatola jamenei a lo que Irán
reaccionó convocando al embajador
francés y clausurando un centro de
estudios franceses enterarán mientras
que Francia defiende la libertad de
expresión y agrega que en el país
europeo no existe el delito de blasfemia
en otras noticias de Irán dos hombres
fueron llevados a la orca tras ser
condenados por supuestamente matar a un
agente de la fuerza paramilitar basic
esto durante las protestas sociales los
ejecutados fueron muham y karami y
otras tres personas están condenadas a
muerte por el mismo caso johnso están en
prisión veamos la historia de Andrés
granadillo dos nuevas ejecuciones de
manifestantes en Irán acusados de matar
a un miliciano islámico se lleva a cabo
la sentencia judicial para la ejecución
de dos personas implicadas en el
martirio de sellet ajamian el 3 de
noviembre estas dos personas junto con
otros dos alborotadores bloquearon la
autopista y perturbaron el tráfico
sabotearon propiedades públicas y
cometieron agresiones y lesiones contra
agentes de seguridad los ejecutados son
muhamed meg dikarami y muham joseini
Quienes fueron detenidos el 5 de
noviembre y condenados a muerte el 5 de
diciembre en un juicio Exprés que duró
sólo una semana según amnistía esta
organización ha reprobado las duras
penas contra caramy y joseini y los
otros condenados como muhammad borugani
Según el padre de karami un ex karateca
los acusados no pudieron elegir un
abogado
amnistía internacional condena la
decisión del tribunal supremo de
confirmar la pena de muerte de Mohamed
borugani condenado en relación con las
protestas en Irán tras un juicio falso
las autoridades deben de tener de
inmediato cualquier plan para ejecutarlo
y anular su sentencia de muerte ya son
cuatro los manifestantes ejecutados
desde que comenzaron las protestas tras
la muerte de Max a mini una mujer que
murió luego de haber estado bajo la
custodia de la policía de la moral por
no llevar adecuadamente
elvislámico hasta aquí las noticias
sigan con France 24
[Música]